okay I have snuck into the building
where jacksepticeye is dreaming and I
have procured my own copy of the stream
broadcasting this to you this is just a
message please don't take this string
down I am giving credit in the
description that counts yeah so just
there he is that's that's him
this is so he's sitting and and I think
he's uh I think he's doing like a
charity stream or something and so yeah
just
like I think this is gonna be better
than the I think this is gonna be better
than the actual stream so I have a
SoundCloud
it's soundcloud.com slash markiplier so
just hit me up there I didn't put it in
the description but if you go type in
your browser in the URL bar at the top
if you type in soundcloud.com slash a
markiplier you can you can find my
soundcloud I've got a few tracks on
there if any producers are watching this
you know just just hit me up and send me
a DM on soundcloud and yeah you'll
you'll find me there anyway um no no
guys don't no I'm serious don't don't
tell anybody about this stream okay just
just uh don't tell Sean and don't report
it to youtube okay listen ID if you're
watching this I have a Twitter I'm just
it's just a stream I'm taking a picture
okay okay cool sorry I think it was
security
so this is this is mr. John septic nose
he's the kind of big gun
I think he's big on Twitter he's like a
Twitter celebrity I think he's just
counting things on the string I give
credit in the description for this guy
I'd forgotten his name but uh yeah just
dumb yeah you listen to my soundcloud
thank you thank you thank you so much if
you give me a follower just uh something
about a door I don't know I wasn't
paying attention to it um no no don't
link the legit stream to see is the
legit stream just so you know yeah
nice shoes mine are better though you
can check out my shoes on my Instagram
and you know that'd be pretty cool also
this stream its effects on it so just so
you know you won't see this on the the
real stream only here at markiplier give
me a sub and a follow under
I gotta go guys I gotta call aa link in
the description for the credit I can I
gotta go